jours alors il est où le titre de ce que
je vois là suis moi je te fuis fuis moi
je te suis
je vais vous dire quand j'ai reçu j'ai
dit voilà c'est compliqué comme si la
rencontre c'était quelque chose de
compliqué comme si le couple c'était
quelque chose de compliqué comme s'ils
se rencontrent et où être à deux c'était
concilier l'inconciliable être à la fois
ici être à la fois là bas je te fuis tu
me suis tu me second une horreur
en tout cas une chose qui est sûre c'est
qu'avant de se suivre de se fuir
il faut se rencontrer
voilà bien rêver qui n'a pas un jour
dans un métro vu un beau gosse à qui on
n'a pas pu parler qui n'a pas été à une
terrasse de café en train de voir une
nana fantastique
entouré de trois copines on a trop peur
de se prendre un râteau et donc on n'y
va pas grâce à apple on va pouvoir
rencontrer
retrouver les gens que l'on a croisée
alors je suis pas là pour faire
évidemment la pub d'apple
je suis un chef d'entreprise avant tout
donc j'ai monté quelques entreprises
dont dailymotion est ce que je voudrais
vous faire partager c'est comment à
partir d'un produit
comment on arrive à monter une
entreprise qu'est ce que c'est qu'une
entreprise à partir d'un produire
d'avoir le produit le produit est bien
sûr je vais rester sur le thème de la
rencontre
le produit dans une entreprise c'est ce
qu'il ya de plus important
il n'y a pas de belles entreprises sans
bon produit un bon produit c'est une
promesse simple la promesse elle est
clair apple vous permet de retrouver les
gens que vous avez croisé alors c'est
pas évident d'avoir une idée et puis
d'en faire une entreprise
et puis de prévoir un succès on ne
prévoit jamais un succès je donne un
exemple pour vous connaissez tous
dailymotion quand on a créé et
dailymotion ont été trois associés on
avait on avait unités cette idée c'était
de permettre aux gens de s'exprimer est
en fait la baseline qu'on avait à
l'époque très important d'avoir une base
d'ail dans des entre dans une entreprise
parce que c'est ce qui permet de dire en
quelques mots qui on est de dire son
identité
il faut que ce soit clair quand on a
créé dailymotion notre première base
line c'était la vidéo est au 21e siècle
ce que le stylo et au 10ème siècle c'est
à dire qu'au 19e siècle pour pouvoir
s'exprimer il fallait savoir écrire
savoir parler maintenant on a tous un
téléphone avec une avec un appareil
photo ou
un capteur vidéo et on peut tous
s'exprimer en prenant son téléphone et
henry en filmant une scène donc ce qu'on
voulait c'était que les gens
s'approprient en fait deviennent des
citoyens du monde des citoyens
journalistes et s'exprimer film ce qui
est autour de comment les comment le
marché comment les utilisateurs son
ampera dailymotion ils s'en sont emparés
de mères différentes ils ont pris ce
qu'ils se sont exprimés avec ce qu'ils
aimaient mecs qui étaient produits par
d'autres à commencer pour dailymotion
longue suite de procès dont vous avez
tous entendu parler
donc voyez que le marché réagit pas
toujours comme avec le produit qu'on lui
offre
et on ne sait pas du tout quelle va être
la réaction du marché
donc en ce qui concerne à peine à peine
c'est une application mobile très
important le fait que ce soit une
application mobile
parce qu'aujourd'hui on vit dans on vit
dans le monde de la mobilité
il n'est pas question qu apple soit un
jour un site internet ou un site web
c'est quoi le monde de la mobilité le
monde de la mobilité si on devait le le
le résumé on dirait que c'est le monde
de la simplicité c'est le monde de
l'immédiateté
alors pourquoi la simplicité parce que
tout simplement sur un écran de quelques
centimètres carrés on ne sauve pas come
on come on surf sur un écran pc où on
peut aller dans toutes les directions
faire des requêtes et c'est sûr sur un
écran sur un petit écran il faut quelque
chose d'immédiat est simple il n'ya
jamais plus d'un clic entre la question
et la réponse
et quand vous fabriquez une application
il faut absolument que ça corresponde à
ça ensuite le monde de la mobilité jeudi
c'est l'immédiateté
pourquoi l'immédiateté parce qu'en fait
la mobilité ça complètement modifié la
manière dont nous fonctionnons tous
autrefois on n'avait pas tous ce
téléphone dans la danse dans la poche
qui permet un tas de choses qui permet
d'être immédiat avec toute chose on
avait une discussion avec quelqu'un il
fallait rentrer chez soi pour vérifier
qu'on n'avait pas dit une bêtise en
ouvrant une encyclopédie ou en allant
chercher sur internet
aujourd'hui on a la moindre question la
moindre hésitation aux prend son
portable et on a la réponse dans la
rencontre c'est pareil il se passer quoi
dans la rencontre avant si on regarde ce
qui se passait avant tender et apple
poser la question est ce que quelqu'un
part mais vous êtes inscrit sur un site
de rencontres je veux savoir c'est sa
personne
c'est marrant parce que tout le monde y
va oui et pourquoi c'est comme ça parce
qu'en fait les sites classiques les
matches mythiques etc
ils sont chronophages
il faut passer des heures à remplir des
fiches profils on n'a plus le temps de
remplir des fiches profils
ils sont déceptif sur déceptif parce que
quand on arrive après avoir rempli la
fiche profil utiliser les outils de
recherche de matchmaking etc
il faut commencer à chat et puis après
enfin au bout de quelques semaines on a
un day tu bats on arrive aux dettes le
mec il a 20 ans et plus et 20 kg de plus
et puis surtout vous êtes mis dans un
process de chat qui fait que vous
commencez à idéaliser une personne que
vous n'avez pas encore rencontré et
quand arrive le moment de la rencontre
et ben catastrophe
donc apple c'est pas ça à peine sait on
ouvre kinder pour parler de mon
concurrent on ouvre l'application et
puis tout de suite on a les profils des
gens qui sont autour de nous tous les
gens qu'on a croisé pas simplement les
gens qu'on a vus mais aussi ceux que
l'on a croisée que l'on n'a pas vu donc
c'est intéressant parce que finalement
on va s'apercevoir qu'on vit dans un
quartier où il ya une personne que l'on
a croisé 50 fois et puis on la connaît
pas elle a l'air sympa elle avoir un
métier sympa c'est l'occasion de la
rencontrer donc c'est ça happen c'est
cet hymne est immédiate et c'est cette
simplicité c'est le fait qu'on a plus
besoin de s'inscrire en un clic on est
inscrit
et puis c'est le fait que ben je vais
acheter une baguette de pain et puis je
le prends mon mon téléphone et je
pourrais aller voir un média mais je
peux aussi voir quels sont les gens qui
sont sympas qui sont autour de moi ce
qu'on a voulu sert introduire et ça
c'est une chose importante réintroduire
dans ce monde digital une part de
réalité faire en sorte en fait que la
rencontre soit comme on l'a fait dans la
vraie vie et dans la vraie vie on la
paie ou la rencontre on l'a fait au
hasard de d'une sortie des gens que l'on
croise d'un regard qui est échangé
c'est ce qu'on a voulu c'est ce qu'on a
voulu c'est vraiment alors chez nous en
fait dans ce monde virtuel de la
rencontre dans cette application
virtuelle
tout commence dans la vraie vie tout
commence par les gens qui sont autour de
vous puis après bon ben on se rencontre
alors je pourrais parler je vais pas
avoir beaucoup de temps
ça c'est le côté produit donc gg je vais
vite parce que je je pourrais vous
parler de sécurité je pourrais parler de
géolocalisation de choses comme ça mais
je voudrais aller vers un ferrailleur
parce que dans une entreprise n'y a pas
qu'un produit
il n'y a pas que le côté glamour du
produit de la rencontre je pourrais vous
en parler je pourrais faire plein de
choses vous faire rêver et c'est il ya
une entreprise c'est aussi quelque chose
d'extrêmement difficile d' extrêmement
ardu je peux vous dire qu'une entreprise
comme apple alors on croit extrêmement
vite puisqu'on à quelques millions de
membres au bout de peu de temps et qu'on
est présents déjà sûrs en europe en
amérique du nord en amérique du sud
en quelques mois et que notre objectif
c'est de venir un player globale en
d'ici début de l'année prochaine
on a un objectif qui est un objectif
extrêmement ambitieux mais aussi quatre
objectifs de une nécessité aujourd'hui
on crée plus un business dans le monde
des nouvelles technologies nationale on
le crée tout de suite européen on le
traite tout de suite internationale et
surtout il faut aller à la vitesse de
l'éclair
je sais pas si vous vous rendez compte
de ce que ça veut dire que de créer un
business qui en l'espace de deux ans
devient mondiale avec des utilisateurs
dans le monde entier avec des
contraintes dans le monde entier c'est
quelque chose je peux vous dire
et donc il ya aussi une partie de ce
business qui est une partie extrêmement
rigoureuse on dit qu'on est un business
data driven c'est-à-dire un business qui
est gouverné par la date a gouverné par
les informations on parlait tout à
l'heure on le joue on entendrait parler
de ce phénomène de big data etc
nous enregistrons en fait par tous ces
gens qui se croisent dans le monde
entier des millions d'informations tous
les jours des dizaines de millions
d'informations aps les jours ces
informations il faut les analyser
il faut voir à quoi ils correspondent
c'est ce qu'on appelle le phénomène des
big data
il ya un nombre incroyable
d'informations et nous pour travailler
là on a besoin dans une affaire de
rencontres comme apple g5 polytechnicien
j'ai un centralien j'ai des gens qui
travaillent sur les big data pour nous
aider à comprendre ce qui se passe mais
la ville d'ataq quand on a tellement
d'informations ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire qu'aussi il ya plein d'informations
qui n'étaient pas bonnes donc la big
data on passe à la smart data et la
smart data dans un monde de réalité dans
un monde de l'immédiateté c'est quoi ben
c'est pas l'information qui date d'hier
c'est l'information qui date
d'aujourd'hui et tout ça c'est que des
mathématiciens des statisticiens qui
vont nous permettre de faire alors je
vous donne un autre exemple moi ce but
beaucoup de temps le cerem le costume en
management alors normalement on se pose
des questions simples on dit bah tiens
on va faire des segments puis les gens
qui réagissent comme ça on va nous
réagir comme ça etc
nous sommes en train de fabriquer un crm
big data c'est à dire qu'en fait on a
des séries data extrêmement importante
que l'on collecte
on va faire des études mathématiques et
statistiques pour trouver de coefficient
de relations entre ces rites data et on
va finir par s'apercevoir que quand il
ya tel data sans même savoir ce qu'elle
veut dire qui réagit comme ça ben nous
il faut qu'on réagisse comme ça ça
s'appelle du crm big data voilà je
voulais je suis arrivé au bout de mon
temps du temps imparti ce que je voulais
vous vous montrez j'espère que j'ai plus
un petit peu c'est comment comment une
idée un produit mais tout ce que ça
implique pour en faire une entreprise et
pour pour créer deux en france deux
nouveaux un leader mondial j'espère que
vous aurez tous l'occasion de
télécharger happen aide pour retrouver